sonny sweeney in case anybody's looking
for that song a liberal city is now
warning people to be careful what they
wear to avoid getting robbed this is
terrible news for judge jeanine the los
angeles police department saying what
we're asking the public to do with these
crime increases is if they're going to
wear expensive jewelry or drive high-end
cars when leaving restaurants taverns
and other locations they need to be
mindful of their surroundings and be in
well-lit areas and rising crime isn't
just a west coast problem new york city
mayor eric adams being criticized for
consulting with chicago's laurie
lightfoot on how to deal with it he
probably should have called ron desantis
yeah like why are you calling the place
where it's back it does kind of it does
explain why new york city is becoming
like chicago there were like uh
how many mass shootings over the weekend
23 victims that is chicago but you can't
wear jewelry or drive high-end cars what
is fabio gonna do uh but this is the
property version of don't go out on a
short skirt right rather than change
criminal behavior through punishment we
law by we the law abiding must change
our behavior we must limit our freedoms
because our political leaders are too
scared of the woke that has infiltrated
our justice system to actually make a
moral stand the woke left has made the
it had has made the criticism of
criminality a sign of racism which is
actually more racist than anything
because if when you when you associate
crime with minorities that's racist and
that is what the hard left progressives
have done and which is why everybody's
really scared it's like you if you i
mean if you actually talk
about what's going on in the streets and
things that you see to people
you people won't like join in and talk
to you because they're out there oh my
god i don't want to offend anybody crime
is now considered like talking about
crime is considered like a a dog whistle
judge what are you going to do
well i'm not in a position to do
anything about it now but when i was i
mean nobody would get away with it just
put these cases in the grand jury look
it's called victim blame
if you wear the skirt too short then you
were asking to be raped you wear a rolex
you were asking to be uh robbed and you
know what we're you know when you're out
there and enjoying the fruits of your
labor if you're lucky enough to have a
nice car then you're teasing the
criminal with it here's the difference
your life is forever affected by it
you're afraid for the rest of your life
looking over your shoulder for the rest
of your life while the criminal's
behavior doesn't change he just goes
through that uh you know swinging door
the justice system rarely will even get
prosecuted let alone booked uh for the
crime and in the end there's only one
way to handle this and it's getting rid
of no bail and it's making sure that we
get rid of these woke prosecutors who
are more interested in criminals than
they are in victims and this is the
perfect example you have people who now
have to change their behavior because
the criminals are allowed to do whatever
they want but my favorite part of this
segment i was reading about mayor adams
our great mayor right we're all willing
to give him in new york city the benefit
of the doubt so he goes to laurie
lightfoot to find out how to fight crime
i don't know if you've been watching the
news for the last 10 years chicago is a
nightmare okay
so um the the reporter says every time i
ask you about violent crime you say
crime is down this is to lori lightfoot
crime is absolutely not down crime in
chicago is up by 34 percent she gets
angry and so he says to lori lightfoot
there's a 178
increase in carjackings in your city
lightfoot's response to the question
you're one of the rudest people i've
ever met
and you know the reporter says i think
carjackers are rude people but this is
what's happening with woke mayors with
woke judges woke prosecutors they have
changed the justice system and they are
literally clamping down on us and our
rights jessica you've been a lifelong
new yorker what do you think
i think having been here
many many years now almost 40 of them
well two away from 40. no no
it was a couple weeks ago um
i you can't call mayor adams woke you
just can't if you've been listening to
how he ran even how he's governing so
far that and if you listen to
progressives reacting to mayor adams you
know that they're not happy with this
this was not the candidate that they
wanted this was more of the tough on
crime candidate actually that kind of
united minority voters and moderate
democrats in the city liberals who are
concerned about
carjackings and things like you know
raiding drug stores and people still you
know bringing the windows at chanel and
whatever else that they're gonna do
i
think that these tips
make some sense considering the current
environment but it's obviously not a
solution and it's not something that you
can say that this is long-term
sustainable to just say don't wear the
nice things that you worked really hard
to get and purchase or that you have to
think twice if you're going to get your
kid a nicer car versus you know a used
car from 15 years ago etc and i think
that these tips for the moment need to
be coupled with the real world solutions
that you're putting forward like this is
how we're changing i have a friend in
los angeles and when he goes out on
dates he will rent a lamborghini for the
night
and he will go get a loner watch to
impress the girl real and then he will
pick her up and then he will roll up at
some hot spot and he will get out in the
lambo and the rolly and he will flex
and that's what they do in la if you
can't do that in la
where else are you gonna do it are you
gonna pull up in a buick and a seiko
watch you might as well be in des moines
iowa no offense la is all about that la
is all about hot cars nice jewelry and
being fake or at least appearing
successful do you even know what people
in la do i have friends in la they have
all kinds of money what do they do i
don't know but they're constantly
impressing me with all of their stuff
now if you can't go out and not have to
worry about getting jacked then
what are you supposed to be your own
policeman you're not supposed to be
checking your six you're supposed to be
you know doing your thing
that's the police officer's job that's
the job of the city leadership if
they're not going to protect you i mean
how about a tax cut right you're paying
all this money for them to protect you
so you don't have to protect yourself
now you're saying you have to protect
yourself well give me my money back
because what am i paying all these taxes
for the whole thing is ridiculous you
know what you know what
you know what your buddy should do what
he should also rent a cop
tell your friend i will that's my tip
right up next the media in a frenzy
again over republicans grilling
president biden's supreme court nominee